This lecture will be,
uh,
some slightly shorter lecture.
Unusual.
What I first want to do is finish off the
discussion of clinical psychology from
last lecture and then have a little brief
discussion about some very interesting
research on happiness.
Um,
we talked,
we ended last lecture with
a discussion of some early,
some of the history of treating mental
illness and we saw that it was rather
gruesome,
unsuccessful and arbitrary
for the most part.
We do better now.
And Dr. Nolan,
Hawk cinema reviewed some of the
therapies but focus on therapies for
depression.
The textbook talks in
detail about therapies for
different disorders including
schizophrenia,
anxiety disorders and so on.
Um,
the question which everyone is
interested in is does therapy work?
And this proves to be
surprisingly difficult to tell.
Um,
part of the problem is if you
ask people who go into therapy,
did you get better after therapy?
For the most part,
they'll tell you that they did.
But the problem is this could be a
statistical byproduct of what's called
regression to the mean.
So the idea looks like this,
this line plots how you
feel from great through OK,
two awful and it goes up and down.
And in fact,
in everyday life you're going to,
some days are going to be average.
Some days will be better than average.
Some days worse than average.
You can plot your semester,
you could do a plot every morning,
wake up or every night
before you go to bed,
you can put yourself on a graph and oh,
come out to some sort of wiggly thing.
Um,
statistically if something is
above average or below average,
it's going to trend towards average
just because that's a statistical
inevitability.
When do people go to therapy?
Well,
they go to therapy when
they're feeling really crappy.
They go to therapy when feeling unusually
that even if therapy then has no
effect at all.
If it's true that people's moods tend
to go up and down after you feel really
bad,
you'll probably improve
rather than get worse.
And so this could happen in a normal flow
could happen just even if there'll be
has no effect at all.
And so simply getting
better after therapy.
Doesn't tell you anything on
the worst day of your life.
You could do naked jumping jacks on a
roof of your college for 10 minutes.
I guarantee you your next
day would probably be better.
That doesn't mean naked jut jumping jacks
or helping you rather just means that
the day after the worst day of your life
usually is not as bad as the worst day
of your life.
It can get worse,
but it's usually just trends to average.
Where you got to do then is you have to
take people at the same point who would
get treatment and compare them to people
who do not get treatment or what we
call a control group.
And this is an example of this.
So this is for people who are depressed.
This is statistically equal.
It started off pre therapy.
They,
they all go,
they all go for therapy.
But because in this example,
there's a limited number of therapists.
Some of them are put on a waiting
list and others get a therapist.
It's arbitrary,
it's random,
which is which making it
a very good experiment.
And in this example,
you can see those who
receive cognitive training,
we're better off,
they have lower depression scores than
those that received no therapy at all in
general.
In fact,
we can make some general conclusions
about therapy therapy by and large works.
People in treatment do better than
those who are not in treatment.
And that's not,
that's not merely because they
choose to go into treatment.
Rather it's um,
it's people who are in desperate
straits who seek our help.
Those who get help are likely to be
better off than those that don't get help.
Therapy for the most part works.
We can't cure a lot of things,
um,
but we can often make them better.
Different sorts of therapy works
best for different problems.
And again,
depression proves to be
an illustrative example.
If you have every day
uni polar depression,
that is you feel very sad and you show
other symptoms associated depression,
an excellent treatment for you is some
combination of cognitive behavioral
therapy and possibly a antidepressant.
Medications like Ssrs,
if you have bipolar depression,
the cognitive behavioral
therapies useless,
but medication is your best bet.
And so on.
Fraud,
other disorders,
each disorder has some sort of optimal,
uh,
mode of treatment.
If you suffer from an anxiety disorder,
cognitive behavioral
therapy can be of help.
If you're a schizophrenia it prime,
you're not going to be a much help at all.
And so different disorders go best
with different sorts of therapies.
Um,
finally,
uh,
some therapists do better than others,
so for reasons that nobody
fully understands or a good
therapist and they're a
better therapist and her a bad
therapist and there is great individual
differences in the efficacy
of an individual therapist.
Finally
putting aside then the
difference in therapies and
the difference in therapists,
does it make sense to say
that therapy in general works?
And the answer is yes.
And this is in large part because of
what clinical described as nonspecific
factors.
And what does this just,
is,
is a term meaning properties that all
therapies are virtually all therapies
share.
And I've listed two of them here.
One of them is support.
No matter what sort of therapy
you're getting involved in,
be it a psychoanalyst or a behavior
therapist or a cognitive therapist or a
psychiatrist who prescribed you medication
or someone who makes you go through
different exercises or it keeps a journal.
You have some sense of support,
some acceptance,
empathy and encouragement,
guidance.
You have.
Um,
you have a human touch,
you have somebody who for at least some
of the day really cares about you and
wants you to be better and that
can make a huge difference.
Um,
also you have hope.
typically there's an
enthusiasm behind therapy.
There's a sense that this might really
make me get better and that hope could be
powerful.
Sometimes this is viewed under
the rubric of a placebo effect,
which is that maybe the benefits you get
from therapy aren't due to anything in
particular to therapist does to you,
but rather to the belief that
things are going to get better,
something is being done
that will help you.
And this belief can be a
self fulfilling prophecy.
Placebo effect is often used sort of in a,
in a,
in a a dismissive way.
Oh,
it's just the placebo.
But will the CBOS can be powerful and
even if it's useless from a real point of,
from a psychological theory point of view,
even if the therapist runs around in
dances while you have dancing on my mind
now while you sit in a
chair and watch him dance,
if you believe the dancing
is going to make you better,
it may well help.
Okay.
That's all I'm going to say about therapy.
Any questions about about therapy?
Yes.
Fair enough.
The question is,
the assumption of regression to the mean,
um,
seems sort of arbitrary because it
depends what the mean is always after the
fact.
You can apply an average to it and say,
look,
this is the average.
But how do you know beforehand?
Um,
it's a good point.
When you talk about
regression to the mean,
it has it adopt certain assumptions.
The assumption is there really is an
average throughout much of your life.
Um,
and things go up and down
wolf in that average.
And for the most part that's
true for things like mood.
For most of us,
we have an average mood and we have
bad days and we have good days.
Um,
it's always possible that you have a bad
day and then from there on in it's just
going to go down and down and down.
But statistically the best
bet is if you have a bad day,
you're going to go back up.
Does it mean it's,
it's
okay
in some way.
You don't even have to see it
from a clinical point of view.
You could,
you could map it out yourself,
map out your moods and the days
where you're most depressed,
sooner or later you're likely to go up.
Similarly on the happiest
day of your life,
odds are the next day
you're going to go down.
And there's nothing magical about this.
This is just because under the assumption
that it really is an average in built
into one of each of us.
If human behavior was arbitrary,
it would be like a random walk,
but it's not.
We seem to have sort of set points and,
and,
and aspects of us that we fall back
to that make the idea of a mean a
psychologically plausible claim.
Yes.
That same study,
how do we know that therapy
that helps in a waiting list?
That's a good question.
Um,
yes,
in that study,
it's a perfectly good hypothesis that
this sort of anxiety of being told,
I see you've come here for help,
we can't give it to you.
Congratulations.
You're a control group.
Causes Anxiety.
In other studies,
the control group doesn't know
they're the control group.
So sometimes you can do an intervention
where you say congratulations everybody
in intro psych who did very low
on the depression inventory,
which many of you filled out,
we're going to do something to you.
And then the rest of the people don't
even know that they haven't been chosen.
So you're right.
It's a perfectly good,
good point.
Knowing you're not chosen could have a
deleterious effect and the way to respond
to that as you have other studies that,
that,
that don't use that same method.
Okay.
Um,
I want to end with happiness.
And it's a strange thing to
talk about in psychology.
Um,
most of psychology
focuses on human misery.
Most of clinical psychology,
there's this psychology we spoke about
through most of the semester on vision
and language and social behavior.
But typically when people
think about interventions,
what they think about is people having
problems and then we figure out how to
make them better.
Their schizophrenia,
they're depressed or anxious,
they're,
they're just not making it in life.
And psychologists try to figure
out how to make things improve.
And in fact,
a lot of information I gave you at the
beginning of lecture last class where I
reviewed all of the disorders,
isn't this wonderful book called Dsm,
the diagnostic and statistical
manual of mental disorders.
If you ever really want to get,
if you really want to diagnose people
and come to have a belief in your own
mental instability,
rousing through that book as a treat,
everything that can go wrong in mental
life from Asperger's syndrome to
fetishize to paranoid schizophrenia
is all in that wonderful book.
Um,
and,
but a lot of psychologists have been
disturbed by the focus of our field on
taking bad people,
people who are broken,
people who are sad and
bringing them up to normal.
And they've started to ask,
can psychology give us any
insight into human flourishing,
how to take people who are,
who had a study,
people who are psychological successes,
how to take people who are
psychologically okay and make them better.
And this is the movement,
uh,
known as positive psychology and it has
its own handbook now the handbook of
positive psychology,
listing psychological strengths,
listing virtues,
uh,
ways,
what psychology tells us about
how we can be at our best.
Um,
some of this work in positive
psychology is in my mind real crap.
Um,
a lot of it is,
is some combination of
new age banalities um,
by people who are striving to get more
grant funds and ended up on Time magazine
on the other hand.
And so some of it is really bad.
You could imagine this attracts every
self help huckster you could imagine.
On the other hand,
a lot of this work is quite neat,
quite interesting.
And quite promising.
And what I want to do is tell you what
I think is the most interesting research
from this movement concerning happiness.
Now,
there are a lot of good
books on this and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna recommend books,
which I haven't been
doing much in this class.
Um,
Marty Seligman is the pioneer of
positive psychology and he's written an
excellent book called authentic happiness.
I'm Jonathan Height is a brilliant young
scholar who's done also done a lot of
work on disgust and morality.
He did the sex with dead chicken
study we discussed earlier.
Um,
this is one of my favorite books by
happiness by nettle because it's smart,
it's beautifully written
and it's extremely short.
And Dan Gilbert's book stumbling
on happiness is a very,
very funny book and Very Smart Book and
is now in a New York Times bestseller
list.
So there's no shortage of books on,
on happiness.
Um,
so the starting point is,
and a lot of research on happiness
starts with a basic question.
How happy are you
and where psychologists.
So tell us on a scale of one to 10 where
five is average tennis super duper the
most common answers.
Interestingly enough,
our high,
there's seven or eight.
How many people in this room would
give themselves a seven or an eight.
Okay.
How many?
A nine or a 10.
All right.
How many attend
good,
good Max stone on happiness?
Um,
it turns out that most people
think that they're pretty happy.
There was a lake woebegone
effect with happiness.
Most people think they're very happy.
If I had most people think
they're happier than most people,
which shouldn't really happen.
Um,
this question,
how happy are you from one to 10
has been asked all over the world?
So,
um,
and it turns out there are slight
differences depending on how old you are.
There are slight differences depending
on your place within a country.
Um,
California versus New York.
There are slight subtle differences
between men and women at different points.
Um,
somewhat paradoxically,
although women are more
vulnerable to depression than men,
still on average,
women are slightly happier than men.
Uh,
the country by country
data is quite interesting.
In one study,
they looked at 42 countries.
The happiest,
well,
let me see.
Um,
the happiest people on Earth.
Well first,
no country believed they were unhappy.
They people in no country
of these 42 countries.
I mean you're thinking there's some really
bad countries to live in and I don't
know if they were tested,
but of these 42,
everybody seemed said
they were above average.
The happiest people on Earth.
The Swiss,
they think they're just like,
they're just,
they're just so happy.
Um,
I was talking to people about this last
night and they suggested chocolate.
Um,
the saddest people on is on the sample.
The Sad Bulgarians.
You are wondering what about Americans.
Americans are actually pretty happy.
7.7 when we are a happy
country full of happy people.
Um,
now I'm gonna talk about a lot of research
says based on the data you get when
you ask people how happy they
are from a scale of one to 10,
but I want to,
I'm going to be honest and tell
you there are reasons to um,
to be cautious about these numbers
and the reasons come from a couple of
experiments.
In one experiment they asked people inside
a psychology department where it was
a photocopy machine.
They went up to people that people were
going up to the photocopy machine to
make copies and when they
were done making copies,
they ask him,
how happy are you with your entire life?
There were two groups,
Group A,
they put a dime on top
of the photocopy machine.
So people walking around,
I'm going to have to move here.
Oh,
a dime.
No other group,
no dime.
It turned out that when asked
how good is your whole life,
Kroo Bay reported greater
life satisfaction overall
in their entire lives.
Um,
another study,
ask people how happy you are if your
whole life on sunny days like today.
And people said they were happier
on sunny days and rainy days.
What's interesting is you can make this
effect go away if you ask immediately
before,
how's the weather?
These were done by phone interviews and
logically what seems to go on is that if
you're asked,
how's the weather you,
oh,
it's really sunny outside,
and then when people are asked how
happy are you with your whole life,
people then say,
oh,
okay,
I'm going to take into account the
Sunniness when I give my answer.
Um,
okay,
so what is happiness?
What do people rating when they're,
when they're answering
these sorts of questions?
And this is an extraordinarily difficult
question and one could devote a seminar
to discussing it,
but one simple answer from an evolutionary
point of view is that happiness,
forget about what is happening
and that's what's happiness for.
Just like we've asked what language is
for or what laughter's for what hunger or
lost is for what's having as four.
And one answer is happiness is a goal
state that we've evolved to pursue.
It's a signal that our
needs have been satisfied.
Happiness is the carrot we're running
towards that makes us take care of our
lives.
We want to be happy.
Um,
an example of this is food.
You're not very happy if you're starving.
You want to be satiated,
you want to be satisfied.
So you seek out food to fill your belly.
Once you've done it,
you're happy.
Um,
Steven pinker summarizes the keys to
happiness in a nicely evocative path.
Passage.
We are happier when we are healthy,
well fed,
comfortable,
safe,
prosperous,
knowledgeable,
respected,
non celibate,
and loved.
How many people here got
all of those right now?
Oh,
come on.
Some people,
oddly enough,
the person who said he was a 10 didn't,
is not raised his hand.
Okay.
Um,
so,
so this is,
and it makes it,
you get all your needs satisfied.
You know,
your,
your belly is full.
People love you.
You're,
you're,
you're getting sex regularly,
you're smart,
you're rich,
you're happy.
But as pinker points out,
it's not that simple.
Um,
here's the problem.
You,
Americans in this century,
you are now healthier,
better fed,
and so on than just
about anyone in history.
Okay?
But you're not happier.
That's the puzzle.
Um,
in particular these studies asking you
about happiness have been around for a
long time.
Um,
people in 1950s did
not make as much money,
did not eat as well,
did not live as long,
suffered for more diseases,
were more vulnerable in
a hundred different ways.
You're there where are as happy as you
are now you are as happy as your parents
were and they were as
happy as your grandparents.
Moreover,
in poor countries,
people don't have the shelter,
the knowledge,
the protection,
the safety.
Yet for the most part,
there's not a huge effect on how rich the
country is and on how happy the people
are.
Furthermore,
there are great individual
differences in happiness.
Um,
among people whose basic needs are met.
For the most part,
everybody in this room is
fed and sheltered and safe.
Some of you are prosperous,
some of you are knowledgeable,
a couple non celibate and,
and put even among that group,
um,
you very and your happiness.
And that's kind of a puzzle.
And to explain the puzzle.
Um,
we need to talk about a few surprising
facts about happiness and our present
three of them.
The first is happiness doesn't change
as much as you think in particular.
Happiness is not as
sensitive to what happens.
Your,
your happiness is not as sensitive to
what happens in your environment as you
might think it is.
Um,
part of the reason for this is that there
appears to be a strong heritable basis
for happiness.
So just as we talked to the domains
of personality and intelligence,
there's some genetic determination,
not entirely,
but some in how happy you are.
And some people talk in terms of a
genetically determined set point.
So you have a sort of
natural happiness level,
maybe a range to put
it in an extreme form.
Some people are genetically
predisposed to be pretty sour,
others,
uh,
to be pretty cheerful.
Well that can't be it.
Identical twins are very
similar in their happiness.
But as with everything
else we've discussed,
they're not identical.
What about life events?
Wouldn't life events change your,
and here we're entering one of the
great discoveries of happiness research.
Think for a moment,
what's the worst thing
that could happen to you?
And then ask how much would
it change your happiness?
Okay,
now think for a moment,
what's the best thing
that could happen to you?
And ask how much would
it change your happiness?
And
the research in happiness suggest that
your gut feelings are probably wrong.
And here's a couple of case studies.
For many people,
a very bad thing that could happen to
you is to be paralyzed from the neck down
in an accident.
It turns out,
obviously common sense
that when this happens,
it makes people very unhappy.
It makes them depressed.
They think their life is over.
They are.
They feel terribly sad,
but not for that long.
After about a year after being
paralyzed from the neck down,
people's happiness comes back up
pretty much to where it was before,
suggesting that there's
a temporary effect,
but not a permanent one.
Many people believe that winning many,
many millions of dollars in the
lottery will make you happier.
And it does.
When you open up that
winning ticket and you say,
I want $100 million,
you say,
Woo Hoo,
you are honest to God,
very happy.
You'd say,
hell,
I'm at 10.5 I am very happy.
A year later you are not as happy.
In fact,
lottery winning may be a
terrible case where people,
where it goes,
the reverse of what you expect.
What happens when you win a lot of money
is it often wrenches you away from your
family or work in your friends and
leads you to depression and sadness,
but even mundane events
that would make you happy,
that you think would make you happy.
Don't seem to last in some
research by Dan Gilbert and others,
they've asked young,
young assistant professors who are
coming up for tenure and tenure in a
university system is a good thing to
get because it gives you lifetime job
security.
Um,
how happy you would you
feel if you got tenure?
How happy would you feel if you didn't
get tenure prior to the last election?
Um,
they ask people,
how happy would you be
if it was President Bush?
How happy would you be
if it was precedent,
Carey?
And it turns out people radically
overestimated the effects of these things.
Having your favorite candidate
win is not such a big deal.
lose is not such a big deal either.
Getting tenure,
not getting tenure,
a really big one,
it happens six months later and
a year later your happiness,
it doesn't seem to be effected.
Um,
the purchase of consumer goods,
uh,
an Xbox three 60,
a nice flat screen TV,
those sorts of things make you very happy
when you open up the package and set
it up.
But this happiness fades
almost immediately.
The moral of a lot of people
are shaking their heads.
It's true.
Um,
I mean,
not,
not for me,
but,
um,
the moral of a lot of this work is we,
we,
we think the things will have big,
permanent and profound effects,
but they need not and they often don't.
Why not?
Why don't we overestimate their happiness?
And the technical term for this,
by the way,
is effective forecasting.
Again,
this is Dan Gilbert's work and the idea
is we are bad at effective forecasting.
That is we are bad at predicting how happy
or sad we will be in the future based
on what's happening to us.
Um,
why?
Well,
couple of reasons.
One thing is there's often a failure to
appreciate the day to day irrelevance of
certain events.
So prior to the election,
you know,
elections happening tomorrow
and I asked somebody who's,
uh,
who's a a die hard democrat,
how would you feel if Bush won?
And the person that I'll be miserable,
it'd be a miserable four years afterwards.
But what,
what often isn't appreciated here is that
whether or not Bush wins will make you
sad or happy after it happens.
But for the most of your day to day life,
you weren't thinking about
who the president is.
I'd be very happy if I want
a huge price and ivy what?
Whoa.
Huge prize.
The Nobel Prize,
a Guggenheim and MacArthur genius
where I get them all at the same day.
What a day.
I am really happy.
But then,
you know,
a month later I'm there and I still got
my regular insomnia and there's nothing
on on TV and you know,
and the plumber is not coming.
And I mean,
you know,
my kids don't respect me and
I can't say and the fact that,
yeah,
but it wouldn't the prize,
it doesn't matter a lot of the things
in life that will make you really,
that,
that you think will make you really happy,
don't have this day to day effect.
Also,
there's the logic of the set point
and this comes to a terrible word.
We adapt.
Um,
right now I'm a guy without a Nobel prize.
I'm kind of used to it.
If I got a Nobel prize,
I'd be a guy if a Nobel prize be happy,
but then I kind of get used to that too.
If I've got a second one who oh,
too.
But then I just get used to that too.
You get used to things.
Um,
you get used to bad things.
Now I don't want to overstate this.
There are some very
interesting exceptions.
Um,
so for instance,
um,
we don't get used to noise.
A lot of research suggests that
if your environment is noisy,
like they're doing
construction around you,
you can't get used to it.
Your happiness drops and
it doesn't come back up.
Your system cannot habituate
to continued noise.
MMM.
We adapt to good things.
Okay.
A winning lottery,
winning a prize,
getting an a.
And of course we have that.
We get used to it
also with some surprising exceptions.
One of the big,
except [inaudible].
One of the other surprises from happiness
research is the effects of cosmetic
surgery,
like a breast enhancement
and breast reduction.
Um,
one of the big surprises is it makes
people happier and then they stay happier.
And one explanation for this is
how we look is very important.
It's very important for how other
people see us and how we see ourselves.
And you never get used to
looking in a certain way.
So if you look better,
it just makes you happier all the time.
So there are these exceptions,
but putting aside the exceptions,
mmm.
The problem of adaptation is sometimes
called the hedonic treadmill.
And the idea is he Dominic for happy.
You keep on running.
But no matter how fast you run,
um,
you stay where you are,
you get used to it.
Habituation is like you,
you put,
you step into very hot bath
but you get used to it.
It's a cold bath.
You get used to it.
Um,
a difficult environment
and easy environment.
You get used to it.
The story is often illustrated
is often an illustrative,
a story from the Bible,
uh,
in Ecclesiastes,
these,
uh,
of a king and his king had it all.
You had gardens,
parks,
vineyards,
castles,
slaves and concubines and they
were both male and female.
Concubines.
We had everything right,
but it didn't make him happy.
And here's what he says,
I hated life.
All is vanity and a chasing after wind.
And there is nothing to
be gained under the sun.
Now in these books I've
talked about at the beginning,
these authors give advice on how
to deal with the nonaccredited.
How do you deal with the fact that
everything that you aspire to,
once you get it,
you'll be used to it and,
and,
and it will lose its value?
Well,
one answer is that possessions
are not the key to happiness.
Okay?
Possessions,
you very quickly get used to
from there.
There are two alternatives.
One is endless novelty.
So one guy,
I forget his name,
wrote a book and he says,
look,
there's a Donna treadmill.
The trick is always do
something different.
Next week,
have sex with someone
you've never had sex before.
Then climb Mount Everest.
You get bored with that.
Become an accountant.
Borning scuba diving boring.
You had endless ideas and,
and that's the possibility.
You never,
if you keep changing what you're doing,
you'll never get used to anything.
Um,
and you'll always be happy.
At least he says that.
Then there's the old guy alternative.
Step off the treadmill,
give up,
give up chasing the whole happiness
thing and then seek out more substantial
goods that might actually not make you
happy in a simple sense of a quick fix of
delight.
But substantial goods like friends
and family and longterm projects.
So the first moral of the
science of happiness is,
is,
um,
that your happiness is
actually rather fixed.
It's fixed and parked genetically.
And it's fixed in part because
what happens in your life,
you'll get used to,
to a large extent,
you raised your hands.
That was,
sorry.
Um,
the second one is
happiness is relative.
So there's a lot of research on money,
power and happiness.
And remember I did say before that it
doesn't matter whether you come from a
rich country are a poor country
as long as your country,
as long as you're not starving to death,
it kind of doesn't matter how rich
your country is for how happy you are.
But that's not the same as saying it
doesn't matter how much money you make.
In fact,
um,
there's a set point,
our range,
but there was some effect on
your salary and on your job,
um,
on your happiness.
And if you're desperately poor,
no matter where you are,
no matter who's around you,
you're not going to be happy.
But beyond that,
your happiness depends on
your relative circumstance.
Um,
and this is an old insight,
a HL Mencken wrote,
a wealthy man is one who earns $100
more than his wife's sister's husband.
The idea is what matters
isn't how much you make.
What matters is how much you make
relative to the people around you.
Um,
and they've asked people this,
what would you rather you want to make?
$70,000.
If everybody else in your office
is making 65,000 or $75,000,
everybody else's making 80,000,
does it matter how much money you bring
home or does it matter how much money
you get make relative to other people?
Well,
they're both factors
but relative it salary.
And in this example people prefer,
prefer this.
Um,
they prefer to be making less if they're
making more than the people around
them.
It turns out that there's research,
um,
on British social servants and,
and their happiness and their health and
the quality of their relationships and
how they loved their lives isn't
depend on how much money they make.
It depends on where they are
relative to everybody else.
We are very status conscious primates.
And your,
and your,
your,
your role in a hierarchy,
your level in the hierarchy plays a sig
as a significant effect on your level of
happiness.
Um,
this is not really a secret.
Uh,
the opera star,
Maria callous and the English professors,
Stanley fish had the
same negotiating strategy
when fish got hired into his department.
According to urban legend,
at least he said,
I don't want to talk salary.
I don't have a particular number in mind.
I just want to get paid $100 more than
whoever's the top person is department.
And that,
that's a guy who knows about happiness.
He walks in each day saying,
I pay more than everybody else.
I don't care how much it is,
it's just more,
and that's relevant to happiness.
We're now in a position to
give some advice to the king.
Summing up first,
going back again to Dr
Knowlton Huxson was lecture,
I think the king as suffering
from mild unipolar depression.
So we usually,
he usually got some SSR,
i's and cognitive behavior therapy.
Um,
I think he needs to move his
castle to quiet part of kingdom.
The noise of a dizzy castle is,
is um,
stressful and
he needs to give up on the compromise.
Um,
he needs to find the queen.
He used to develop social relationships,
join a club,
um,
get involved in charities.
Maybe a hobby.
The final finding is a bit of
a jump to a different topic.
But sorry,
you raised yes.
The question is did you become used
to changes in social interaction?
Um,
an example is solitary
confinement or prison.
Um,
people get used to a lot of things.
It could be that,
that in those examples there was a
shift in status as well and social
relationships and how you think
of yourself relative to others.
So that may be difficult to recover from.
If you're a popular at
Yale and you go to prison,
you're not going to be very happy at
first few days in prison probably.
But then suppose you
get popular in prison.
People like you,
you're,
you're the head of the book
club and everything and,
and,
and everything.
Um,
my dad has,
you know,
you'd rather not be in
prison then in prison,
but you probably be a pretty,
if you're a cheerful guy here,
you'd be cheerful guy in prison.
MMM.
The final case is involves judgments of
the pleasure and pain of past events.
And like I mentioned a Nobel prize
a little while ago as an example.
But the work I want to talk about is
actually from the one psychologist who's
alive,
who's won the Nobel prize.
Sorry,
one of the ones who's won the Nobel prize.
Uh,
Daniel Conoman and um,
and he became interested in happiness.
And you remember him from
his rationality research.
And this is some work on happiness.
Uh,
here's an example.
When you see the movie marathon,
man,
Rob's a dental torture scene.
MMM.
Imagine you're going to the
dentist and he's torturing you,
or it's like a,
it's like a cleaning,
but it's really painful and it's terrible.
You're,
you're sweaty,
you're squeezing it,
and then you sweat and
it lasts for an hour.
And then when it's done,
the dentist leans over and says,
we're done now if you want,
we could stop.
But if you want as a favor to you,
I have five minutes,
I could top you off with some mild pain.
This may seem like a
very odd thing to ask.
Here's the alternatives.
What do you want a dental procedure that's
very painful for an hour or a dental
procedure.
It's very painful for an hour.
Sorry about the s there and
then some additional mild pain.
Who votes for a,
you got to choose one.
Who Votes for Aa?
Alright,
who votes for B?
Okay.
Um,
here's the big finding.
The big finding is yes,
be involves more pink.
It's true.
A is an hour of pain.
B is a,
is an hour of pain plus a
few minutes of more pain.
Seems like a no brainer,
but when you have a or B and you
have to remember it later on,
you'll have a much nicer memory of B.
Then a condom in his insight is
when you think back on events,
you don't just add up the amount
of pleasure or pain you experience.
Rather your memory is highly skewed
to peaks and then to endings.
And you could imagine
this in the first case,
a you lean and say,
Oh God,
that was terrible.
Oh,
be you.
Leave as it.
Oh,
that was mildly painful.
There was any caramel in the middle there,
but it ended.
Okay.
Mild pain,
it turns out in general,
endings matter a lot.
Um,
condom and did his research with both
in a laboratory where you could make,
give mild pain by getting them to stick
their hand in freezing cold water and
with people under growing extremely
painful colonoscopy procedures.
And it turns out that if you want to
give people a good memory or a less bad
memory of it,
horrible events,
topping them off of some
mild pain will do the trick.
Um,
in the end,
well ending's matter
both of these examples.
Um,
a party that's hugely fun for 90%.
Then the last 10%,
somebody slaps you in the face
and pores dip on you or something.
Um,
so 90% of good stuff,
10% bad stuff versus 90% people are,
are,
are slapping you in pouring dip on yet,
but,
but then 10%,
whoa.
That was a really good,
when you think back on it,
if you just added it up
a would be much better.
But,
but B has this huge Paul,
um,
because of the power of,
of how things end.
Um,
so ending's matter.
So I'm going to end things now.
I'm first going to do a few things
before saying anything more.
I want to thank the teaching
fellows that are Sunnybank,
Eric Sheree's,
Jane Erickson,
Isaac,
Your Rudy,
Greg loud and Coleen McCrank.
I think they did a superb
[inaudible].
MMM.
We basically reviewed all the psychology.
Here's a promise.
Every note we started with at
the beginning of the semester.
Um,
I think you're now in a position to
answer or at least consider answers about
these topics,
about topics such as dreams,
testimony discussed,
memory,
depression,
language humor,
and even a little bit about good and evil.
Um,
this is an in abroad intro survey class
and the field of psychology is broad and
we've just gotten started.
Um,
if you're interested,
this is a great department.
There's some amazing scholars
here and some amazing teachers.
And,
um,
there are courses that go into detail
about just about every topic I talked
about.
If you're interested in memory or,
or,
or social interaction or mental illness,
I can point you to some great courses.
I'm not taking any sophomore advisees
next year because I'm on leave in the
fall,
but um,
but you should feel free to come talk
to me if you want any specific advice or
suggestions.
Now I know not all of you are going
to end up majoring in psychology.
Um,
some of you will choose
cognitive science instead.
Um,
but in,
and a more serious note,
I know for some of you this is
the last maybe the first bit,
but the last psychology you'll ever take.
And so I want to close this course,
um,
by emphasizing to themes.
Okay.
The first one is a bit of humility.
There are some very basic questions about
the mind and I've tried to be honest
about this throughout the course.
There are some very basic questions about
the mind that nobody knows the answer
to yet.
We know the brain is a
source of mental life,
but we don't have any understanding
at all about exactly how this happens.
But how a physical object,
a lump of meat can give rise
to conscious experience.
We know that about half of
the variants in personality,
but half the differences between
people are due to genetic factors,
but we don't know how to explain
where the other half happens.
It has to be experienced,
but we have no real good theories of
the sort of experience that makes one
person adventurous and
another one timid one,
you know,
one bidder in one satisfied.
We know a lot about the social influences
that can drive people to do terrible
things to one another.
But we don't know the answer to that.
Maybe harder question of why some of us,
some people are immune
to these influences,
why some people do good things,
perhaps even heroic things regardless
of the circumstances that they find
themselves in.
So there's an enormous
amount left to do it.
It's,
it's an exciting field just because
there's just so much more we need to,
we need to understand.
Um,
the second theme is more optimistic and
this is the idea that we're going to
eventually come to answer these questions
and many more questions through the
sorts of methods we've been discussing
this semester through constructing
scientific theories,
evolution,
evolutionary neurological,
developmental,
computational,
and testing them through experimental
and observational methods.
Um,
this is the idea that in the end,
the most important and intimate aspects
of ourselves and our beliefs and
emotions,
our capacities to make decisions,
even our sense of right and wrong can
be explained through constructing and
testing scientific hypotheses.
Now,
the reason why I'm optimistic is I think
there's been some success stories where
we really have learned some surprising
and important things about the mind.
And there's no reason to expect this way
of proceeding to fail us in the future.
Um,
in my very,
very first class on the brain,
I ended by talking about
people's worries here.
And I'll be honest that some
people find it a scary prospect.
Some people believe that a scientific
approach that our mind takes a special
nurse away from people that
it diminishes us somehow.
And,
um,
I don't agree.
Um,
if there's anything I've tried to persuade
you through the course is that the
more you look at the mind and how it
works from a serious scientific point of
view,
the more you come to
appreciate its complexity,
its uniqueness,
uniqueness,
and its beauty.
Um,
this has been a great course to teach.
Thank you for coming and
good luck on the final
[inaudible].